they're hell early two-thousands homes a
sound it's a bumper Nova murder I have
no idea why I pretty much went to kiss
by rose for so he's I have no idea why I
was like that just needs to be the theme
is do okay obviously it's all made up on
the spot
I'm not kiss boob in every is gonna be
bad man so can't I scenarios abandoned
forever so oh I swear that was one of
the first jokes I made was at all these
freaking songs from around the year 2000
sounded like particularly in superhero
movies yes are they cold and dead yeah
even though cuz there there's I don't
miss it I didn't think they're ready cuz
there's a song I I there's a song I had
to switch it out for copyright reasons
but there's a song when when she's
hitting the bags uh you know it's like
even the women sung like that yeah
murder tower every song from that time
period sounded like that this is that
they were all of them that sounded like
that used in comic book movies yeah well
no and I think I said the longer version
for song I was like you know they're all
Sheeran like this except for the boy
pants with that was shit so and I can't
sing that well like that so I'm just
gonna sing like videos Oh like that was
it was like boy bands and that serve
Creed Nickelback top Oh bullshit you are
here are real thoughts on daredevil web
you know it's pretty it's pretty bad but
it's interesting actually talking about
that now because we just am I'm not sure
which one of these coming up first but
we just did a review of um Cinderella
the why be my voices will soar there was
a lot of screaming but I was saying um
you know sort of the this film is trying
to operate too much on you know like the
logic of something that's not really
supposed to have logic that much logic
to it you know that fairy tale
anymore focus on the emotion and this
one had almost the opposite Proms in bet
you could tell it's like this is a
checklist of the superhero stuff that
all superhero movies were like it that
they you know Batman blade Spider Man II
and all this stuff especially the ones
too
beyond dark and broody and it's just
interesting seeing this list fall
through but really no reason why it's
not like somebody was like I really want
to tell this story about this guy who
dresses up like this daredevil this
superhero because it's a really unique
story that's ever been done it's so
clearly from all these other aspects
that were knife and that popular at the
time they were trying to come back the
best way I can describe movies like
these are paint-by-number yeah like
literally just like somebody threw a
bunch of numbers in a script and said
okay
hit all of these numbers and then they
just assemble them together and you get
this painting that just looks like a
paint by number painting like it's good
enough I guess but it's just bland and
there's a picture like well that's why I
think it's so great I mean just the
comparison to now with like those comic
book superhero movies and back then
because like you know Dark Knight was
also very brooding and very dark and
then it begins and stuff but it did do
better with it and it took it to like a
new level it's like let's see what we
can really do with this we're dead
daredevil like I said it looked dark and
honestly didn't look that bad I mean for
when Yuki looked all right no no I mean
like when you hear Ben Affleck is gonna
play this guy in a red outfit with
little horns and stuff like that like
I'm surprisingly not laughing at him I'm
actually like okay like he actually
looks okay and the fat was laughing a
little okay well no when he started like
daredevil his character so but I some
things I'm not sure can ever translate
that great and the daredevil outfit at
least am an incarnation I just yeah
today I could take it was not it was not
god-awful but it was the kind of thing
that I'm just like it's a little silly
you can tell he was trying to do the
high was obviously inspired by Batman he
saw Batman said I want to do Batman
uh cuz everything looks like it it
follows you know so money I do get
reported electric nachos yes which I
know is like the comic book characters
name but it still sounds ridiculous you
know I was allowed a change for that or
at least a change in tone at least if
you're gonna actually have a character
Colm at well and they try they play up
the Batman thing like am I
my one of the bad guys or am I doing
this right
yeah but they yeah but they don't really
do anything with it he just I love at
the end where he's just like kingpin no
you're gonna go to prison but I'm gonna
get up yeah and I'll be waiting justice
is served
yeah you'll probably Joe a ton more
people while you're out and I'll be
catching up and now I'm not gonna kill
you even though I've already killed
somebody at beginning in this movie
which each I haven't which means I
probably done this multiple times yeah
he killed bullseye I'm like why I know
how you know this is The Count of Monte
Cristo trick there was always a woman
problem that's like now that I have had
my revenge and everything is satisfied
and I've left a pile of dead bodies in
my wake I dedicate my life to God works
that way you found an interesting out
who turned about the early 2000 movie
which we actually like but even the
director was like yeah they maybe do
this ending and it's bullshit ya know
yeah yeah I've ever talked about the the
one with them
God kills guys yeah um but yeah so it's
a em aspectos when I came out I was
actually kind of looking forward to it
cuz like there were one or two dark
superhero movies at the time but they
weren't like necessarily a thing they
were trying to become a thing um and
Ella it was just interesting
like I said they sir felt like they were
still like nobody was taking comic books
seriously so we had to make them darker
and grittier comic books included comic
books got like insanely dark uh you know
it's just in the design and the way out
of them well it was that thing where we
got dark and grittier because of Tim
burns Batman's and then Batman and Robin
completely destroyed that ya know I said
it was as though he's going to take a
comic book seriously then blade came
along and then there was this and yeah
there was this period of time where I
swear to god everything either looked
like blade or Jon singers first x-men
movie and the irony of it is blade style
is pretty cool Jon singers force x-men
movie pretty forgettable yeah like II
I'm not even saying that the movies bad
but I'm like when it comes to the set
design and the costumes I mean what
costumes there were none in that movie
like I loved her birth
yellows fabrics yeah you know and
so-and-so everything felt like just
watered-down versions of blade or x-men
um I think you know Ryan singer by the
way think it's a Johnson Johnson
I meant Bryan Singer sorry um so yeah
and that's this movie's probably it just
I feel like I'm watching half Blade half
a little touch of x-men touch a Batman a
little bit of spider-man and like it
just it just feels like I don't know
it's like the milk left it's like the
soggy cereal left in milk it just I'm
like this could have been good but it's
no longer good anymore yeah no I get the
feet if it came out like maybe three
years before the first Batman came out
like probably would like to fine but
it's like we know these tricks we've
seen this before we know how much we
trying to do if you come up before Tim
Burton's Batman I think it would have
played pretty good ya know because we
we've seen this before and we know like
we've gone through this experience while
you're trying to give us you know one
and say this is totally different
totally new by the way it's clearly not
see all I could think of when I was
white actually this was the biggest
thing throughout the entire movie all I
could think of was I would much rather
be watching dark man like cuz it I said
there's a baby yeah yeah it was a unique
comic book movie and really dark and
gritty and kind of goofy and kind of
funny and like that's all I was thinking
was like I just really want to watch
dark man right now not finish this movie
like it just other movies have done it
better is it's probably its biggest sin
and then just I don't know if it's a
lack of passion because I've seen the
director's cut which is better but it
still wasn't great so but they're just
it just feels almost like a computer put
this movie together like this has worked
yeah again yeah yeah and it's like the
paint-by-number aspect like just hit
these notes and you know I mean we were
having fun with that like is when his
father dies is just like uncle band and
then what we were joking that when he
doesn't stop that crime it's Uncle Ben
getting shot yeah but it just yeah it's
just here's the same set of notes here
again and again it's it's like a
McDonald's hamburger like you're just
like yeah that's okay but there are
better burgers yeah
that was at the point where I was
realizing like us a lot growing up a ste
teenager you know and I hate school and
stuff like that and literally in the
dark I yeah I wouldn't guess having a
Burton corner inside yeah I me loved the
dark stuff I would drive you think Doug
I'm a tortured itis and stuff I think
around that point your teeth artiste and
I think around that point I was
realizing like the darkness has to have
a point it has to serve the story first
it can't just be dark and that's it has
to serve the character has to serve the
story has to be doing something that
hasn't been done a million times before
and this was the first I really started
realizing cuz at the time there was
really there were very few things that
were like dark at least visually dark
kind of Burton was it maybe one or two
other directors but not many and now
it's sort of like its own genre well I
wasn't help to that there is no
chemistry between any of the actors in
the film not just the romantic leads
just I feel like none of these actors I
feel like they there was great chemistry
between Michael Clarke Duncan and Colin
Farrell okay there were like oh yeah
beautiful okay okay I'll give you those
two great they are amazing by the way
between those two only but but Michael
Clarke Duncan and Ben Affleck no an
applicant Jon Favreau no yeah you know
is nobody really feel felt like they
were clicking it was almost like they
were shooting separate movies
simultaneously yeah or maybe they were
on green screens the whole time and
digitally inserted together that's what
it felt like um so yeah it's it's hard
for me to say it's like the worst cuz
like I said it's at least at least has
some idea of the dark stuff that is one
of them I will say it's light it's the
dark stuff like ironically it's not the
worst but it is one of the most bland
and forgettable which is so strange
given how it you know given this style
and sort of a concept of this this blind
guy who's a superhero but even they did
because you read daredevil I didn't I
know the initial layout is the same but
it in the comic is there more of a
purpose to him being blind because it
also seemed like it served no purpose in
this film except my cool blind vision
thing well his other sights hit sites as
other senses were high
because of it but were there
disadvantages at all to him being
blanka's here it's like he can almost
see better than normal people can well
yeah if you're able to disable any of
his other senses like particularly
hearing I mean they touched upon that
with the bells ringing and stuff like
that but you know or you could worry you
could water you can overcrowd his senses
but I mean but even here my through a
crowd cheering at the boxing match is a
come on dad get up he could tell who
fell to the ground over a screaming
crowd it seemed like it just didn't make
a difference in it but all superheroes
to some degree the power mostly just
comes down to and that makes me super
awesome and doing something and a lot of
times it's just strength so it's another
way to give him strength via an
alternate means I mean really it's just
a metaphor for let's for like
superheroes that can also be you know
handicapped like it's the idea that you
know even though you're handicapped you
know you can you can still do something
that basically the powers you have even
when you're handicapped it gives you a
different outlook on life and something
that other people don't have like blind
people do have a heightened sense of
hearing some people I found out recently
can see more colors than other people
which must be interesting so it you know
is there any point what's the point of
any superpower most of the time the
point of any superpower is this and it
makes me strong at least this is kind of
a fun metaphor for people who you know
do have you know particular handicaps or
something and you know they can be like
hey well that's awesome you know
somebody that's like me and you know
they can do cool stuff too it's somebody
look up to you no no no but like okay
for example like he could hear certain
things about being you notice the player
says you know I could hear the police
siren all away from here saying that
they've got to come and get you okay
even with those superpowers I doubt that
but whatever
it gives him sort of this advantage that
normal people don't have but then I
would have to say something else has to
still encompass the blindness outside of
just the sound like there was one
scene I really like when bullseye he
throws the bikinis trying to catch it
but then explosion happens and the wave
and the sound impales his senses so now
he sees five of those cans like okay
that makes sense
but on top that's like he doesn't even
need the cane so I'm thinking like there
has to sort of be like a blessing and a
curse with it and it seemed like there
wasn't that much of a curse with it I
cuz it seemed like he could still pretty
much see well that's also - because it
didn't focus no pun intended
yeah it didn't focus as much I pick on
his purse alivers this here's the
superhero ask man what little it did
it's like I'm gonna have a fight out in
the open with this girl and nobody's
gonna think this is weird I guess my
walking cane is also my weapon hello
nobody puts that together and that's
like a Batman did carry around his watch
just wallet hey it's Bruce wicked bitch
is why would you carry that yeah that's
pretty good
umm umm but I know I guess I don't get
the point it's like what's the point of
any superpower like it well not because
like you know is Superman he's got
incredible strain you do all this cool
stuff but then he also has this weakness
you know the Kryptonite that to us is
like nothing but the ability okay like
the ability the super here I mean he
could hear criminals having
conversations and yeah like I like
Superman in that which movie maybe was
returns one of them where he's up high
listening to all the cell phone
conversations and he zeroes in on a
police CB radio reporting a crime and
decides to go down there and you know
think of it like that there are many
advantages now did the movie play all
those up no but I think the comic does
know that's why I'm asking yeah okay
yeah that's a problem in the movies
interpretation they take his powers and
they kind of just package it into one
little thing time limit fair enough yeah
like I mean we hadn't been a better
movie maybe would have focused on more
aspects and come up with more creative
ways and you know but I honestly that
didn't bother me that much I thought I
got an idea of how it would help him is
I was just trying to get like I said try
and get an idea of like how the powers
kind of work I just got to a point where
I was gonna say myself I see even blind
uh but in the comics it sounds like they
play a little bit more the both II
badges
disadvantage he does have kryptonite
like if you play noises too loud you
know you could try to remember the $10
there are a couple comics where they
found ways to kind of scramble is he
hearing late yeah like there are ways to
do it um so yeah okay um traffic much
else I mean like we just we just did the
review so um and here a big I um I still
miss michael clark dawn again every time
i see him on screen there's some
actresses still can't believe are going
and that is why i'm just like you damn
it like that guy was so great he was
perfectly I know kingpins supposed to be
white but he was probably it's one of
those cases where it's like the color
the skin doesn't matter when you find
somebody that's so embodies a character
yeah like when I heard he was kingpin
like I believe he didn't link yeah I was
like this is one of the greatest ideas
anybody's ever had like and then of
course the movie sucks but uh yeah I
thought that was just brilliant casting
well Marika is somebody told me that
like as the character looks bad in the
comic but actually not it's like some
sort of weird morphed muscle he's like
so I and he's perfect for that because
it's like he has that look about him
yeah like it's this guy like he's is
this guy just really tall and kind of
chunkier this guy really tall and
fucking muscular as hell and in the suit
it's kind of hard to tell he he's a
fucking bird yeah no no no he's
obviously you know he's got the muscle
um so but it's a proportion for Colin
Farrell yeah he's I'm not a coming for
me baby you know when we saw him like
cuz we had seen this movie back when it
came out and even back when it came out
I couldn't stop laughing at him I'm like
this guy is amazing with that don't like
Ross I like haha blank stare oh he's
like the poor man's Brad Pitt in that
movie but it's great like am I so nuts
my favorite is that you know he made me
miss yeah like he's yeah I love that I
love they like some aspects round like I
really like that aspect of he wants to
go out to tear devil for free just
because he made a mess like that that's
comic books that's great and that's a
great addition of the character um and
uh I will say surprisingly this movie
the action see
particularly the kind of the first one
in the bar uh it shot with a lot of
flashing lights and a lot of kind of
shaky camera I was shocked I could
follow it okay it was actually decent
action for all the effects and let's
remember between Michael Bay and the
Bourne movies really action directing is
gone straight downhill like there's no
concept of like how to properly shoot an
action see and it's just and we're going
to insert some digital explosions here
and check the camera mmm
the that's it so I think some of them
maybe we probably at the time wouldn't
have thought this is the greatest action
soldiers was dicen el spray no no I'm
I'm saying there are yeah okay there's
some out there like there's good action
scenes out there we've seen them like I
thought the action scenes in Godzilla
were really fun um but I'm saying those
are the exception now they're certainly
not the norm yeah everything is just
shaped the camera like crazy and just
there's an explosion maybe you can make
out a flying wheel like you know so
maybe because of that we're just looking
back on this like hey this is pretty
good cuz I remember when I saw the film
originally I was like yeah this isn't
that good yeah by Memling maybe we're so
used to the crap now yeah maybe I don't
know um but yeah I was shocked I catch
we make it out as well as I could um so
uh yeah at and you know efflux not awful
he just isn't much of anything yeah
there's not much to him
I don't hate it like I didn't hop on the
hate Ben Affleck train um cuz a lot of
what happens in daredevil is not a
flicks fault it it was a perfect storm
of just things that going right up near
any level like the reason hey Electra is
the worst thing in the movie I mean
let's be honest I didn't so maybe the
rider bad yeah oh it's terrible the
reason so many people I think hate
Affleck is cuz they had just an exact
opposite next to a whole time with Matt
Damon who was just like unbelievably
charming and pick of movies and stuff
and Affleck you know at the time be very
full of himself and he picked bad movies
and stuff so it's one of those things
where it's like but she 10 act you just
gotta find the right movie and you know
what we'll see if a man were
is I I don't think I'm not judging this
as like will it be a good idea because
honestly did I think he was innocent but
yeah I didn't ruin it either I think he
was just kind of Miss Cass and I don't I
don't know there were there clearly
wasn't a clear direction on this film
from anybody
there was studio interference the
director at his vision Affleck I think
was just left out hung out to dry like
with so many competing people telling
him what to do from different like it
just the whole thing just felt like one
of those studio created messes where
like they over tinkered with it so I
think it's more matter of um will you
turn your cell phone off so this is the
second video yes so well we're wrapping
up though anyway um so yeah I am fishing
gone girl I think he can actually be an
interesting bet it'd be different but
like watching that one and just seeing
kinda obvious secret he has but he's
kind of for your cures manic and hey
instead I was like yeah okay I can
actually see this work okay so I don't
know if I have you seen daredevil I
think uh Colin Farrell can be a very
good Joker Joker ha ha ha ha ha why you
series so um that's about it I like I
say I think yeah there's not basics here
this just not that much to talk about is
this is very bland movie yeah so we'll
definitely have a more apart interesting
one for the next one so yeah that's a
bit we'll see you later
take care